ceos are the highest paid people in the
world period but unlike most of us who
take our salaries and cash ceos
generally receive the vast majority of
their compensation in stock for example
in 2020 tim cook was paid 281 million
dollars but only three million of this
was cash this means that only about one
percent of tim's compensation was in
cash now that's already quite extreme in
comparison to us average people but
founder ceos generally take the strategy
to a whole another level
everyone from elon musk and steve jobs
stop mark zuckerberg larry page and
sergey brin have all taken one dollar
cash salaries in the past this isn't to
say that they weren't paid at all though
they often receive hundreds of millions
if not billions of dollars worth of
stock elon musk for example recently
unlocked a 23 billion compensation tier
even on the years that these guys don't
get a stock compensation they're
compensated in the form of travel
security housing and so on but what's
even the point of this why take a one
dollar salary
one dollar salaries aren't a new
phenomenon by any means in fact they've
been around since the early 1900s but
the first time they gained significant
prominence was during world war ii
unlike the one dollar ceos today who
received extraordinary amounts of
compensation through other avenues the
original one dollar ceos actually only
earned one dollar well kind of
you see it during the height of world
war ii the us government was struggling
to recruit taunted individuals much of
the young talent was sent to the war
while the others preferred to record
private companies so a few prominent
ceos decided to help out the government
for free and set an example this
included executives like philip reid the
ceo of ge and william not senate the ceo
of gm these guys were basically
volunteering for the government but the
law prevents the government from hiring
unpaid volunteers so they of course
decided to pay them out one dollar per
year and these guys became known as the
dollar a year men it should be noted
though that these guys were still being
paid their regular salaries from their
companies so it's not like the total
compensation was only one dollar
but their work at the government
specifically was truly only awarded one
dollar by the end of the war the u.s
employed a one thousand dollar minute
and these guys served in all sorts of
positions william nutson for example
started off in the national defense
advisory commission before becoming
lieutenant general and then the director
of production william was an invaluable
resource in this role because his
knowledge of running efficient factories
and scaling up production were unmatched
before the u.s joined the war they were
producing just 3 000 aircraft per year
but by the end of the war they are
producing 300 000 aircrafts per year
cargo and navy ship production also went
through the roof which helped the war
effort astronomically after the war
ended though most of these guys returned
to their original jobs full time or they
retired and most people forgot about the
one dollar salary up until 1979. at the
time the automotive ministry had been
devastated by the oil crisis and the
company that was hit the hardest was
chrysler things got so bad that chrysler
needed a bailout from the government and
to show that the company was serious
about spending the bill of money
effectively chrysler ceo lee iacocca
decided to take a one dollar salary if
you're not familiar with this man he's
an absolute icon within the automotive
industry and he made one dollar salaries
the default pr move for wealthy ceos the
next prominent example of the one dollar
salary is steve jobs when steve joined
apple in 1996 the company was on the
brink of bankruptcy so it's no wonder he
settled for one dollar salary especially
given that he was already a billionaire
thanks to pixar and as the dot-com
bubble burst we saw dozens of ceos
follow his lead but this was really the
last time that the 1 salary was truly a
sacrifice
since then the one dollar salary has
become more of a strategy than a
sacrifice
one of the greatest perks of taking a
one dollar cash salary is that you can
receive significantly larger
compensation through other avenues while
also minimizing public scrutiny as you
might have already guessed on average
one dollar ceos are paid significantly
more than regular ceos on average one
dollar ceos do earn 623 dollars less in
salary nine hundred forty one thousand
dollars less in bonus and one hundred
and seventeen thousand dollars less in
other forms of cash compensation this
adds up to a total of one point six
eight million dollars less in cash
compensation however on average they
also earn 515 000 more in options 1.5
million more in stock and 1.5 million
dollars more in other forms of non-cash
compensation this adds up to an extra
3.5 million dollars worth of non-cash
compensation this means that the average
one dollar ceo earns 1.87 million more
than the average ceo in terms of total
compensation not only does one dollar
cash salaries help these ceos minimize
public scrutiny but it's the main reason
that they're able to earn so much in the
first place here's the thing many of the
biggest companies in the world run at
little to no profit so they can't afford
to pay massive cash salaries take tesla
for example it wasn't till 2020 that
tesla posted their first full year of
profitability do you really think that
tesla could afford to pay elon a few
hundred million dollars per year much
less 23 billion dollars of course not
even now tesla only has 17.5 billion
dollars in cash so if they were to pay
elon 23 billion dollars they would
literally burn through their entire cash
reserves even paying him a few billion
in cash would be an extremely
irresponsible move but if we're talking
about options or stock that's actually
doable here's the thing when companies
give employees and executives talk
compensation they don't actually pay for
the stock it's not like the company buys
the shares from the stock market and
then awards them to the employees rather
companies are allowed to create shares
out of daenerys as long as that advised
by their employee or executive
compensation plans now just because the
companies creates the shares out of
denir doesn't mean that the stock is
free
rather all of the existing shareholders
of the company are basically agreeing to
dilute their own stakes to pay for this
talk compensation for example when elon
was paid 23 billion dollars tesla's
valuation hovered at around 1 trillion
so shareholders had to dilute their
stakes by about 2.3 percent for elon to
get paid such a massive amount but
that's an extreme example even elon
doesn't usually get paid tens of
billions usually his pay is closer to
something like 500 million and compared
to tesla's big market cap that's only
0.05 dilution as you can see stock
compensation allows companies to offer
extraordinary salaries without
compromising their own balance sheets
and if you think about it it's truly
quite brilliant but what it's not is a
sacrifice
aside from earning a far greater salary
many speculate that one dollar salaries
allow ceos to get away with a much
smaller tax bill the idea is that
executives don't have to pay taxes at
all until they sell
so they'll only have to pay capital
gains taxes as opposed to ordinary
income tax which is a lot higher but
this isn't actually true
executives do have to pay ordinary
income tax when they exercise their
stock options and given the magnitude of
their salaries they usually end up
paying 40 50 in income tax elon for
example had to pay 11 billion in taxes
last year now elon cleverly made it seem
like he was selling stock because people
wanted him to but really he had to you
see it elon had stock options that
translated to 22.8 million shares of
tesla and all of these options were
expiring in august meaning that he had
to exercise or sell these options by
august whenever you exercise or sell
options though it counts as an ordinary
income event in the given that each year
of tesla was worth over a thousand
dollars at the time exercising 22.8
million shares was equivalent to 23.5
billion worth of ordinary income
at a 40 tax rate this translates to 10.7
billion in taxes there's really no way
of getting around this and elon only had
until august to exercise these stock
options so he decided to sell while
tesla was near its all-time highs and he
also made it seem like he was doing his
civic duty when really he was forced to
pay a large tax bill if he wanted to
exercise his options now that elon has
paid ordinary income tax on this stock
he can hold for a long time and he'd
only have to pay capital gains taxes in
the future but this isn't really a tax
advantage if he was paid 23.5 billion
cash it wouldn't have really changed
anything he would have still had to pay
ordinary income tax on the initial
payment and he could have still
benefited from long-term capital gains
tax if he invested the cash the only
time that you can avoid ordinary income
tax altogether is when you get equity
from founding a company and the original
value of your shares is zero thus the
ordinary income tax on those shares is
also zero and you only have to pay
capital gains tax whenever you're paid
with stock that actually has a value
though you do have to pay ordinary
income tax now some of you guys who earn
stock compensation may be saying that
you didn't have to pay ordinary income
tax on your stocks and the likely reason
for this is that your stock was awarded
in the form of isos or incentive stock
options isos are special stock options
that are only tax capital gains but the
only problem with isos is they're capped
at 100 000 per year so this benefit
isn't really applicable to the
executives that we're talking about and
the idea that one dollar ceos can just
avoid ordinary income tax altogether is
simply not true
while one dollar ceos may not be able to
get a tax break by taking their
compensations in stock they do get one
more massive advantage which is
stakeholder morale there's very few
things that give shareholders more
confidence than knowing that the ceo is
all in
and most ceos are more than all in and
given that they borrow money on their
stakes to actually fund their lives this
means that if the underlying stock went
to zero the ceo would be screwed as they
would literally lose 99.9 percent of
their wealth take elon for example
bloomberg estimates that he only has
three billion cash even after selling
tens of billions of dollars worth of
stock
this means that before he started
selling tesla late last year he likely
had less than one billion dollars in
cash
now this is not a bad amount by any
means and it's not like he's going to go
homeless if his companies collapse but i
don't know about you but i wouldn't want
to go from 300 billion to 300 million
overnight and this is likely extremely
strong motivation to not let any of his
companies go bankrupt this isn't as big
of a concern when we're talking about
mature companies with solid cash flow
but for startups ceos taking one dollar
salaries is a strong commitment for
example amazon stock crashed 95 percent
after the dot-com bubble jeff bezos
being all in during this time period was
no doubt quite a statement at the end of
the day one dollar salaries came about
due to times of hardship but over time
they've evolved into a marketing ploy
and a strategy for earning bigger
compensations they don't have a bunch of
tax advantages like many assume but it
does do one job better than anything
else when a ceo takes all of their
salary in stock they don't get paid
online shareholders also get paid and
thus far there has been no greater
symbol of allegiance and loyalty to
shareholders than taking a one dollar
salary would you be willing to take your
entire salary in stock comment that down
below
also drop a like if you thought this
video explained one dollar salaries well
and of course consider checking out our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hardy i'll see you
guys on the next one